Last week, I did a video about pedestrian crossings,
and while I don't want this to turn into 'things you might not know about British pedestrian crossings,'
Well, there is one more thing, and quite a few people got in touch to say I should point it out.
There is a secret button, or nodule, on the bottom of these things you push when you want to cross the road.
And what that little secret nodule is, is a sign for anyone who is blind and deaf,
or partially blind and partially deaf.
Or, who is partially blind and at a crossing that does not make a beeping noise when it's safe to cross,
which is a surprising amount of crossings.
Because that little nodule rotates any time that signal turns green, as we will now see.
Because don't forget, disability isn't a thing that turns on or off,
you don't just get people who are entirely blind but fine every other way, or entirely deaf but perfectly able to see.
You get lots of folks who might be able to walk around safely in the world, but who couldn't make out that signal,
and who couldn't work out the beeping from the background noise, even if there was some.
So that little nodule means it's safe for a lot of British people to cross the road,
and that is something you might not have
[laughing over the sound of a bus]
Why do I do videos near roads?
THAT is something you might not have known!
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]